et
soir bonsoir
obama ne serait pas loin je vous parle
en deux minutes etc ou tard vous pensez
que moi je veux me prouver rivoire
écoutez écoutez c'est vrai d'un premier
abord dès que vous voyez l'humoriste et
comédien vous pensez que la la il vient
pour faire rire là là je suis pas venu
pour faire rire donc rester tranquille
je tiens déjà vous affirmer que devant
vous vous avez quelqu'un qui n'est pas
l'alcool
je suis analphabètes comme on dit donc
je vais vous parler en français français
d'abord où là c'est ce que je vais vous
parler c'est que vous allez comprendre
vrai ou faux bond je tiens à vous de
cigares et déjà que j'ai vécu une vie je
peux mourir maintenant et a même pas de
souci mais la vie en elle même c'est un
combat la vie est un roman mais combat
terrible qu'il faut mener de bout en
bout
la vie c'est comme deux boxeurs qui
monte sur un ring pour se cogner tac tu
donnes des coups mais tu en reçois jusqu
à ce qu un seul il ya un qui sait sans
ébranler qui prennent un coup fatal et
qui tombe mais c'est là où le moment où
tu penses que tu es puis à qui a reçu un
coup fatal que tu t'apprêtes à tomber
celle là qu'il faut prendre le taureau
par les cornes que la vie commence là le
combat commence là
le gain de la vie commence là ton échec
aussi celle là si tu a programmé dans la
tête que tu va échouer tu tombes il ya
rien à faire
et bien moi je suis michel gault je suis
né à gap ayant un petit village situé à
quelques encablures de la ville de
gagnoa
c'est là que je suis née du père et le
même cultivateur mais pauvre pauvre kg
du pauvre ces pauvres le pauvre c'est
celui là même qui n'arrive même pas à
manger une seule fois pas là
dans la journée avoir à manger une
banane même c'est toute une des
difficultés cela que je suis né alors
mais comme tous les enfants de mon âge
il faut que je batte à l'école à 7 ans
je suis allé à l'école à notre âge un
autre temps il fallait avoir 7 ans +
même peut-être même plus avant de faire
cp1 c'est aujourd'hui on va cependant
l'école à partir de 3 ans moi j'avais 7
ans mais j'ai vécu une enfance très
difficile assez régulier et à cette 1re
m'inscrire à l'école comme tous les
autres enfants comme je le disais j'ai
pensé c'est bien
cp 2 c1 arrivé au c2 j'ai senti à moi
une chaleur pas possible dans mon corps
c'est comme si on avait allumé du feu
comme s'il y avait un foyer dans mon
corps mes os
je sentais que mes os se tordait et
j'étais le seul à savoir cette atrocité
que je vivais et cette maladie s'est
emparé à moins et a commencé à me donner
une autre forme
une fois que je ne voulais pas du tout
mais je continuais quand même dans
l'alcool
ces deux là maladie sanctuaire
s'accentuait arriver à un tel moment je
ne pouvais plus marcher je pouvais plus
marcher
je suis resté à la maison allez
maintenant vers les soins à s'il faut
guérir
tu n'es pas bon le sentais tu peux pas
aller à l'école à l'hiver le médecin les
guérisseurs
mais rien mais c'est tenu quand même à
terminer l'année scolaire ces deux
pendant les vacances j'ai continué à
sept îles la guérison après les vacances
il faut reprendre le cours c'est certain
je reprends mais cette fois ci la malade
est descendue jusque dans les pieds et
je n'arrivais plus à me déplacer
j'avais pas pour des matchs une canne
avec la deuxième calme ma main droite
donc là car je m'appuie sur la cades
mais poule b le deuxième pied je me
faisais aidé par le bras d'un bras droit
et c'était difficile et mon école était
situé à un kilomètre de mon lieu
d'habitation de l'école de mots lieu
d'habitation jusqu'à l'école je pouvais
tomber au moins 10 fois avant de me
lever
j'arrive à l'épaule en l'état mais le m
me battais copieusement pourquoi tes
amis arrivent à l'heure et toi tu
arrives à l'étagé bien messieurs
regardez ce que jarre dur actuellement
et dunant 6 te laisses ça va donner
l'occasion aux autres élèves d'harvard
et à je te laisserai pas il me by me
punit je rentre pas à la maison pendant
que mes amis rentrent au manger moi je
reste là j'attends pire quand je sors
dans la cour de l'école
je suis la risée de tous les élèves
tout le monde se moque de moi mais
regardez ça l'art mais sans génie mais
ça s'en soucier
mais celui-là il a bouffé quelqu'un puis
la ceinture mais tous les maux à telle
enseigne que moi finalement je me
cachais pendant la récréation je vais
pas tarder à la classe je me suis resté
seul il restait seul quand je reviens
ils sont tous derrière moi
regardez le il va tomber il va tomber
effects images tome mais il ya quelqu'un
qui disait la force d'un homme c'est pas
de ne jamais tomber mais c'est de se
relever
une fois qu'on tombe
et je puise à cette force en moi j'avais
cette force de me relever et de
continuer le combat
j'ai continué avec sept ans ce problème
jusqu'en classe de cm2 arrivée celle de
c'était plus était plus possible
c'était une paralysie totale alors mais
je vous dis paralysie totale tandis que
je suis couché il faut même quelqu'un
pour fois me faire lever mafieux faire
asseoir je n'arrivais pas à me tenir à
mi mât soir tout seul alors pour moi
l'école terminée ça pour vous c'est
pourquoi je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
vous avez en face de vous un half
analphabètes ma classe du cm2 j'ai même
pas bien fait la place du sérieux je me
suis arrêté là
mais j'y crois encore
malgré que tout était fini j'étais
couché la lpm ample qui a débarqué du
bukina faso et qui m'a vu la coucher
mais enfin c'est un moment
moi je la pour moi c'était la mode
maintenant puisqu'il n'y avait plus
d'espoir l'autre arrivait il m'a vu que
celle du maire ce petit vous le laisser
mourir là alors qu'il ya des
possibilités de le récupérer dans les
paroles de la chanson et à la danse on
étale en tout cas pas le faire avec lui
où tu veux et soit le 6 il a pu guérir
c'est tant mieux s'il n'a pas pu gagner
aussi c'est dieu qui l'a voulu et il me
prend dilection bukina faso
mais en passant par coup mais là ce
qu'on veut pas te prendre le train à
bouaké arrive à coups mais à la gare
routière
il me dit bon atteint moi là je vais
voir un de tes encore quelques pas dans
un village à je reviens te récupérer
puis on continue
j'ai dû mettre pourquoi je vais pas mais
pas celle là elle me ressort j'ai dit à
ce plan que je viens avec moi et il m'a
dit ceci
arrivé à roue mais laisse le petit là
bas parce qu'avec la foire qui la façon
il est là si tu viens avec lui si mes
voisins voire se moquer de moi
quand il m'a dit ça j'ai pas pu me
retenir j'ai pleuré tout le temps mais
c'est plus quand il est revenu il m'a
trouvé les yeux enflés complètement
tuméfié
on a continué mais je me suis dit quoi
dieu existe il n'existe pas pour une
seule personne tout le monde autant que
nous sommes sur cette terre là où je
vais
mon seul objectif c'est de guérir et
revenir si je guéris et que je reviens
je me battrai contre vents et marées
pour réussi dans la vie et ses temples
il verra dieu merci en continu sur le
burkina faso 3 ans de traitement dans un
village 3 ans de traitement dans un
village
heureusement j'ai pu prouver usage du
même jeu revient alors sur abidjan
monsieur gagnon là ma ville natale
j'arrive au village tout le monde est
surpris de me voir sur pied pas de
béquille pas de cannes rien je marchais
tranquillement comme vous le mois vous
ne voyez actuellement mais je me suis
dit ça ne s'arrête pas là la vie n'est
pas le regarder faut foncer
alors j'ai recommencé à faire les petits
métiers l'école pour moi c'était fini
puisque les parents n'avaient pas
d'argent tu m'as sûr il est le court
alors au collège pour moi les quoi se
terminer il faut maintenant être
autodidacte pour pouvoir avancer parce
que l'école ça te met sur la voie de
pouvoir guider et après maintenant tu te
prends en charge tu continues tu fais le
reste j'ai eu quand même le béaba de
l'école il sait lire ses écrits
ok je commence avec les petits métiers à
gagnoa
j'allais gérer le boutique vous itp 6000
francs par mois
après ça réussit à les vendre du café à
la gare routière ceux qui connaissent la
garde des deux gagnants je vend du café
là pendant un an après je suis allé
vendre de l'eau à travers la ville après
ça j'étais pompiste après je suis allé
encore apprendre le métier de
l'instruction tv radio j'ai fait tout ça
mais finalement ça j'avais une passion à
moi c'était le théâtre
donc j'ai intégré la troupe théâtrale le
fromager théâtre de gagnoa à mes heures
perdues du fait de mes répétitions mais
à un certain moment je me suis dit il
faut aller plus loin
donc si j'allais dire à mon père au
village je vais abidjan y met du nom à
bigard là bas il ya des gens qui sont
bien bâti bien valide mais touareg
appdata fort de jeunes handicapés
tu peux faire quoi un habitant reste ici
on va se débrouiller d'une on a bien
mieux bien mieux
alors qu'est ce que je fais j'ai pas
d'argent pour partir pas le transport je
commence à voir les travaux champêtres
je travaille dans les champs les gens on
me donnait 300 francs par jour tu
commences à 8 heures tu finis à 15 ans
de 300 francs j'ai pu j'ai pu rassembler
5000 francs comptez-vous même 300 sites
a pu avoir 5 ne savent combien de jours
de travail
ah c'est ça donc je débarque en ville ou
prendre le car les agents aujourd'hui
gagnant
mais à l'époque il avait déjà chanté
alors abidjan abidjan
c'est ça dont je prends mon temps
direction habillage arrive j'intègre le
groupe
le fétiche et burins d'abrogation suis
allé m'inscrire dans cette troupe du
théâtre j'ai trouvé à dire le couple ans
que vous connaissez pas déjà
dao il était déjà dans la cette troupe
j'ai j'ai dit madame inscrit ils m'ont
regardé et puis m'ont posé un casse toi
tu le fais tu es là j'ai dit oui toi
comme ça là tu fêtes théâtre j'ai dit
oui on est battus ça fait quoi il dit
ben j'ai déjà fait du théâtre mais je
vais essayer
on y monte moi tout ce que tu sais je
mange je le cite qu'un quotidien en msl
nul
mais j'ai commencé à intégrer des
troupes après le fétiche julien nature
le théâtre le à sa théâtre le gasc à la
compagnie nationale de théâtre de côte
d'ivoire
le fétiche et pep les guignols d'abidjan
le vidal et qui avec le working qui a
fait tout ça et aujourd'hui je suis
legault que vous connaissez
[Musique]
mais je me dis quoi mais tant que je
suis là il faut avancer
mais faux sacs à dos et sur le passé
pour se propulser dans le futur parce
que quelqu'un qui oublie son passé il
peut pas vivre tu as dit tu peux pas
connaître la vie tu oublies ton passé
regardant l'autre au visage ça te permet
d'avancer
moi c'est ça qui fait ma force alors je
voulais m'adresser à la jeunesse la
jeunesse qui est aujourd'hui le fer de
lance la jeunesse quel espoir de toute
l'afrique
la jeunesse qui est aujourd'hui cette
base sur laquelle l'afrique compte cette
jeunesse qui rivalise avec les enfants
blancs en europe aux états-unis un peu
partout dans le monde
cette jeunesse qui aboutit internet
c'est une excuse n'a pas s'asseoir et
attendre de l'aide parce que c'est vous
qui êtes les dirigeants de demain c'est
vous c'est sûr vous l'afrique de demain
c'est sûr vous la fugue la côte est des
mains c'est vos galères qui devaient
être les pneus et le moteur de l'afrique
de demain rivaliser allait foncer
prenez vous prenez en charge compter sur
vos potentialités foncé comme un beau
diable natal vous ne vous lassez pas
pour dit non j'ai mon cousin 15 minutes
l'autre député l'autre personne n'a
boudé des personnes y'a que vous prenez
vous à charge quire potentialités et
foncer comme de beaux diables
c'est cela c'est comme ça que la foule
peut avancer
soyez avant gardiste genest le cours du
voyage jeunesse d'afrique
soyez avant gardiste mais pas moi je
qu'est ce que je compte faire ou alors
qu'est ce que j'ai déjà commencé à faire
j'ai en train de construire une école
une école où je peux apprendre ce que
j'ai déjà appris à la jeunesse france
vers la jeunesse
mon petit savoir même si c'est surtout
autodidacte diem petit savoir aussi que
je peux transmettre à cette jeunesse 2,7
d'ouvrir une fondation récupérer tous
les petits groupes qui sont dans quoi
ils sont beaucoup d enfants qui ont
perdu le sens de la vie qui a perdu
l'espoir et tu veux vraiment s'attacher
à la vie à leur écoute
et leur forme et leur donner un nouveau
souffle de vie leur donne un fouet pour
pouvoir se prennent à sale dans la vie
c'est cette fondation qui est en train
de mettre sur pied aussi alors je
voudrais vous remercier et dire à la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui
la jeunesse africaine soyez avant
gardiste je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]